in alberta the blockade at the coots
border crossing is over the protesters
packed up and left this morning one day
after police made a series of arrests
and seized a cache of weapons and
ammunition heather urix west has been
covering this story since it began
heather
donna after 18 days it's over and
protesters say it was the discovery of
weapons here that brought this blockade
to an end
they left town just after breakfast
a long line of tractors trailers and
trucks it's too bad that we have to
leave but it was very everybody that
really their best and to get freedom for
everybody in canada
and it breaks our hearts they'd vowed to
go on blocking the border crossing until
all coveted restrictions were lifted but
protest organizers say this changed
things a cache of weapons including long
guns handguns and body armor these
weapons were brought by people who had
the intent on causing harm 13 people
were arrested most now face charges of
mischief and weapons possession three
have also been charged with conspiracy
to commit murder our message has been
one of peace peaceful protest
and to keep that message strong we felt
the best decision was to move out
as protesters left coots at a second
protest camp near milk river police took
names and collected information still
under investigation who brought the
weapons to couts and what was their
intent the canadian anti-hate network
says one set of body armor seized by
police displays the local of a group
suspected of promoting hate and violence
we recognized immediately that the
patches were the flag of a network
called diagon basically they're like a a
neo-fascist acceleration acceleration
this militia
just before noon tuesday the canadian
border services agency confirmed the
kutz border crossing had reopened to
cross-border traffic a relief to many
industries who moved tens of millions of
dollars worth of goods through here
every day donna
heather urex west near milk river
alberta tonight thanks heather